we also assume that drew brees is going
to retire something strange is going on
and i'm not here to say he's not going
to retire
but three weeks ago today sean payton
told us on pft live
that they're about a week or a week and
a half away from an announcement from
drew brees and it's always pointed to
retirement
once drew brees restructured his
contract and took a
24 million dollar pay cut for this year
ostensibly to allow the saints to carry
a much lower cap number under his name
until june 2nd
at which time they'll process the
retirement and divide his lingering cap
hit over two seasons giving them more
cap space this year
once he did that that was as clear an
indication
as it could possibly be because if he
plays this year he's making a salary of
1.075 million
but here we are he hasn't retired and
there's just a weird vibe
ricocheting around the nfl that maybe
drew brees
is going to show up and say i'm doing it
for one more year
and i'm happy to do it for 1.075 million
and i think
seeing tom brady a team that
the saints swept in the regular season
brady and the buccaneers
the bucks beat the saints in the
playoffs win the super bowl
is drew brees in the process of
convincing himself
that if he comes back for one more year
they've got
as good a chance as anyone to climb the
mountain and he can walk off into the
sunset with his second super bowl trophy
i i you know this tom brady super bowl
experience in
in early 2021 i think has screwed up a
lot of teams
and screwed up a lot of quarterbacks and
it may have drew brees thinking
i do have one more run left in me
uh it'll be interesting my i don't see
him coming back and playing i'd be very
surprised you know he
we know he was out in la and he lives
out that way
anyway in the offseason maybe just a
matter of setting up a press conference
when he and his family
and everybody can get to new orleans and
they can have the big
celebration maybe that's what it is i
don't know i'm going to be real
surprised if he comes back and plays i i
think we saw the end
of drew brees last year and and
especially playing for 1 million and
perhaps being
a backup in new orleans i mean frankly
they should have pulled him in the
playoff game if they were going to have
a chance to come back and they didn't do
that you can't do that to drew brees so
can you bench him can if he comes back
can you tell him
hey you're going to be a backup if you
come back i mean this is this is going
to put the saints in a very tough
situation i think if he
does choose to come back mike mickey
loomis the gm of the team has
said that drew can stay as long as he
wants but sean payton from time to time
has
has made it clear that he's ready to
move on you could argue they were ready
to move on
last year and it may result in a candid
conversation between peyton and brees at
some point but
sharing for peyton to say three weeks
ago that they expect an announcement the
next week week and a half and we're
three weeks later there's a disconnect
somewhere
between brees and the saints and
until he officially does it we we just
have to wonder
what's going on and yeah and this is
this is this
look you got a long relationship between
team and player and it's hard to be the
one who cuts the cord
and it could be that breeze is
not not something he planned out maybe
he had every intention of retiring but
it's just something that he can't
can't bring himself to say and do and at
1.075 million i don't know if i'm the
saints
if he's willing to be a backup or you
know compete for the job and we'll
decide who the best quarterback is and
he's not going to be upset that he's
only making 1 million dollars this year
if i'm sean payton i may say fine come
on we'd love to have you around just
understand that
you know maybe you're only going to play
half the time maybe you want to play 30
of the time whatever the case may be
i think sean payton will find a way to
make chicken salad out of whatever lands
on his death
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports